but invariably in American politics
foreign affairs is not is not the
subject even even in these times that
gets the sense of urgency among the
electorate amazingly the war in Iraq has
been going on since 2003 that is not the
most important issue to a lot of voters
and with no end in sight by the way
despite the so-called success of the
search the success of the surge is
entirely based on a temporary temporal
security situation and certainly has had
no great effect on the political
ramifications of of these three ethnic
groups in Iraq that's that's the
unfortunate fact it is not easy to get
the American electorate writ large
focused on the danger of pakistan or
afghanistan or what happened here
pocketbook issues I mean James Carville
you know wasn't completely crazy when he
used to say it's the economy stupid